[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تاكيد عراقي على الهويه
والاستقلال والسياده الوطنيه بعد تصريحات
لمستشار الرئيس الايراني اشارت الى ان
العراق مجال حيوي لهويه بلاده وثقافتها ان
بغداد هي بمثابه عاصمه لايران نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر وتداعياته في
محورين الى اي مدى تتسق المواقف العراقيه
المعلنه مع التمدد الايراني داخل
العراق ما هي الحدود الحقيقيه العلاقات
بين العراق وايران في ضوء ما يجري على
الارض
قال ممثل المرجع الديني الاعلى للشيعه
بالعراق علي السيستاني ان قبول العراق
مساعدات في حربه على من سماهم الارهابيين
لا يعني غض الطرف عن هويته واستقلاله هذه
التصريحات جاءت بعد ايام من حديث لعلي
يونسي المستشار الخاص للرئيس الايراني قال
فيه ان العراق لا يمثل مجالا حضاريا لنفوذ
طهران فحسب بل هو مجال حيوي لهويه ايران
وثقافتها ايضا وان ايران تعتبر بغداد بهذا
المعنى بمثابه عاصمه لها تصريحات اثارت
دهشه الخارجيه الايرانيه الا انها تفتح
الباب امام الحديث عن العلاقات بين ايران
والعراق في ظل التطورات الاخيره على
الارض تعود العلاقات العراقيه الايرانيه
الراهنه ومستقبلها الى واجهه الاحداث ومع
تقدم القوات العراقيه والميليشيات
المسانده لها في بعض محاور الحرب على
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه خاصه في معارك
التكريت الراهنه ومع استمرار ترحيب مختلف
القيادات العراقيه السياسيه والدينيه
بالدعم العسكري الايراني لهذه القوات
بعنوان محاربه الارهاب توضع علامات
استفهام كثيره حول الحدود الحقيقيه لهذه
العلاقات واتجاهاتها ونتائجها ان ذلك لا
يعني في حال من
الاحوال بانه يمكن ان نغض الطر
عن هويتنا
واستقلالها ولا يمكن ان نكون
جزءا من ايه تصورات
خاطئه في اذهان بعض المسؤولين هنا او هناك
حديث يعيد للاذهان وصف علي يونسي مستشار
الرئيس الايراني اخيرا للعراق بانه حاليا
لا يشكل مجالا حضاريا للنفوذ الايراني
فحسب بل مجالا حيويا للهويه والثقافه
الايرانيه ايضا وبهذا المعنى تعتبر بغداد
بمثابه عاصمه لايران على حد قوله حينها
استنكرت الخارجيه العراقيه ذلك واعتبرتها
تصريحات غير مسؤوله لكن الثابت براي
كثيرين ان الدعم الايراني العسكري يزيد من
نفوذ ايران في العراق ويشار هنا الى وجود
قاسم سليماني قائد فيلق القدس بالحرس
الثوري الايراني في معارك استعاده التكريت
حتى ان هادي العامري زعيم ميليشيا منظمه
بدر دع العراقيين الى انشاء تمثال للرجل
قائلا ان امريكا لا تستطيع تحرير قريه
عراقيه واحده رئيس الوزراء حيدر العبادي
نفسه طالما اثنى على الاسناد الايراني
للقوات العراقيه لكن حلفاء بلاده
الامريكيين قد لا يشاطرون له الراي فقد
اعتبر الجنرال ديفيد تريوس القائد
الامريكي السابق لقوات التحالف في العراق
خلال تصريحات لصحيفه لوفيغارو الفرنسي
ان الخطر الاول في العراق لا يتمثل في
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وان الخطر
الايرانيه اكبر
بكثير معنا في الاستوديو للنقاش في موضوع
هذه الحلقه الكاتب والباحث السياسي
العراقي الدكتور لقاء مكي ومعنا ايضا من
بغداد عباس الموسوي مدير المركز العراقي
للاعلام ومن عمان الدكتور حيدر سعيد
مستشار المركز العراقي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه لمناقشه هذا الموضوع اهلا
بضيوفي الكرام سيدي عباس المسوي ضيفي من
بغداد عندما ينقل هذا الكلام عن مستشار
الرئيس الايراني ويصف العراق بانه ليس فقط
مجرد نفوذ استراتيجي وعلاقات مميزه بين
البلدين وانما هو ايضا امتداد حضاري
لايران وان بغداد هي عاصمه ايضا لايران ما
الذي يفهم من هذا
الكلام
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بالحقيقه انا يعني
اشكر هذا الشخص على تصريحه لان اثبت ان
الولاء العراقي هو ولاء للعراق وليس ل كما
يدعي البعض ان ولاء المجموعات في العراق
او شيعه العراق الى ايران ضمن الارتباطات
الطائفيه ردود الافعال العراقيه
اثبتت اثبتت ردود وزاره الخارجيه ردود
الاحزاب العراقيه ردود المرجعيات الدينيه
العراقيه اننا نتعامل مع الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في ايران بما تقد للعراق ومصلحه
الوطنيه العراقيه موضوع السياده العق قبل
رد الفعل سي سيد عباس قبل رد الفعل ماذا
عن التصريح في حد ذاته كيف تفسر وتفهم
عندما ينقل هذا الكلام عن مستشار للرئيس
وليس مجرد شخصيه عامه او محلل سياسي او
ناشط سياسي في ايران ولكن ينقل عن شخصيه
لها وزنها ولها
مكانتها يعني الرجل ليس ذا وزن ثقيل ونحن
ندرك جيدا من يحدد السياسه الخارجيه
لايران هو مكتب السيد خامنئي وليس رئيس
الجمهوريه
الايرانيه المستشار الرئيس الايراني ضمن
مجموعه من المستشارين وليس له وزن او ثقل
سياسي لو لو كان هذا التصريح جاء لمستشار
السيد خامنائي بالتاكيد له انعكاس على
الشارع حتى الايرانيين تبروا من هذا
التصريح عندما اصدرت السفاره الايرانيه في
بيروت تكذيب او تصحيح لتصريحات هذا الشخص
انا ما يعنيني في العراق ليس تصريحات ما
يهمني ردود الافعال العراقيه اجاه هذا
التصريح والموقف العراقي المتماسك اتجاه
السياده العراقيه بكل انواع الشرائح
المجتمع العراقي ضيفي من عمان الدكتور
حيدر سعيد ما نقل عن المستشار مستشار
الرئيس الايراني هل هو تصريح شخصي برايك
ام يعبر عن خلفيه ربما تشكل طبيعه الفهم
وطبيعه النظره الايرانيه الرسميه للعراق
وعلاقته
بايران يعني شكرا اولا استاذ عبد القادر
على استضف احييك واحيي ضيفي الكريمين
يعني لا امير الى تبسيط التصريح مثل ما
فعل الاستاذ عباس الموسوي بالتاكيد هناك
فئات داخل منظومه الحكم في ايران ذات
توجهات
قوميه شديده التطرف طبعا والجدل في ايران
حول النزعه القوميه وعلاقه القوميه
الايرانيه بالاسلام جد الطويل ربما غير
معروف لل للقاري العربي للاسف الذي لا
يعرف الثقافه الايرانيه جيدا هذا بالتاكيد
يعبر عن رؤيه جزء من منظومه الحكم في
ايران غير غير
الطريقه المحرفه التي تناول بها الاعلام
العربي تصريح يعني يونسي لم يقل بغداد هو
لم يستعمل تعبير بغداد اصلا استعمل تعبير
العراق ولم يقل انه اصبحنا امبراطوريه
وبغداد هي عاصمتنا الخطير في التصريح هو
الجزء اللي ذكرته حضرتك الذي قال انه نحن
امتداد ثقافي وحضاري مع العراق وحده
ثقافيه
وحضاريه مع العراق و بمعنى اما ان نتقاتل
او نتحد انا في تصوري جزء كبير من منظومه
الحكم في ايران ما معنى الامتداد الحضاري
يعني هل كان يونسي سيقول نحن امتداد حضاري
مع السعوديه مثلا او مع تركيا انا في
تصوري هذا يعبر عن تصور جزء من وجزء اساسي
من منظومه الحكم في ايران بان العراق بلد
شيعي تحديدا ان العراق بلد بهويه احاديه
هي الهويه الشيعيه وهذا هو معنى الامتداد
الحضاري مع العراق في حين نحن العراقيين
نعرف العراق بانه بلد متعدد الهويات
والاثنيات ولا يمكن للعراق ان يختزل بهويه
احاديه وفي تصوري تفجر منظومه الحكم في
العراق منذ تاسيس العراق الحديث في مطلع
قرن هو بسبب محاولات اختزال العراق بهويه
احاديه عربيه سنيه شيعيه وما الى ذلك
بمعنى لم تنبني رؤيه للتعبير عن العراق
بوصفه بلدا متعدد الهويه بلدا بهويه مركبه
لا يمكن ان يختزل بحده وطالما تظل منظومه
الحكم بالعراق تريد ان تقصر العراق على
هويه احاديه سيبقى العراق بلدا متفجرا بكل
تاكيد دكتور لقاء اشار ضيفي من قبل قليل
من بغداد وقال انا اشكر المسؤول او
المستشار ايراني لانه اثبت واعطى دليل على
ان ولاء العراقيين
للعراق كيف وجدت رد الفعل الرسمي وكذلك
المرجعيات مما جاء من قبل
هذا المسؤول الايراني وان كان مستشارا
لرئيس الجمهوريه برايك يعني اعتقد انه
ردود الفعل كانت في حدود المناسب قياسا
لطبيعه الاوضاع في العراق يعني لا تنسى
انهم الان يعني في في حاله حرب وايران
متدخله بشكل واسع النطاق فاغضب ايران بشكل
عنيف الان يعني على مستوى سحب سفير مثلا
او يعني تصعيد المساله دبلوماسيا هذا امر
غير ممكن لذلك كان الامور في حدود
الاعتراض الشفهي من قبل وزاره الخارجيه
بعد بضعه ايام وليس فورا وايضا في خطبه
الجمعه هذا اليوم لكربلائي ممثل السيد
السيستاني في كربلاء ايضا كان فيها اعتراض
ضمني يعني لم يذكر ايران بالاسم لكن كان
من الواضح طبعا انه يقصدها انا لم اطلع
حقيقه على ردود فعل اخرى شعبيه او حزبيه
من اطراف اخرى ربما هناك ردود فعل لكن انا
اعتقد انها في اطار خجول يعني ربما مثل ما
اشرت لانهم محرجين في كيفيه الرد على
ايران باقصى حد يعني لو كان من قال ذلك
تركيا مثلا الان وان الموصل لو قال التركي
ان الموصل جزء من تركيا ونعرف ان هناك
اطراف في تركيا حتى الان تطالب بالموصل
كيف سيكون رد الفعل اكيد سيكون اقوى يعني
وبالتاكيد يعني مثل هذه الامور اي رد فعل
عنيف واوحد دبلوماسي سيكون مبرر جدا بل
ومطلوب لانه العراق الان يعاني من ازمه
سياده وهناك استهدافات عديده له ليس فقط
من ايران من اطراف عديده ايران متهم الان
باحتلال العراق حتى من الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي على العراق ان يعني يثبت تماما
انه خارج نطاق السيطره على الاقل نعم
فليقم علا سويه مع اي طرف وما فيها ايران
لكن هو خارج نطاق السيطره الايرانيه الى
حد الاستيلاء كما يشاع الان دعني انقل هذه
النقطه الى ضيفي من بغداد س العباس المسوي
عن كيف تنظر بغداد لعلاقتها بايران والى
اي مدى ما هو موجود على الارض يعكس فعلا
حقيقه كيف تنظر بغداد الى علاقتها
بطهران يعني بالتاكيد
العراق بنت علاقتها مع الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في ايران من خلال خلال المصالح
المشتركه ومن خلال المواقف انا اتصور
العلاقات العراقيه الايرانيه الان باحسن
حالاتها لان وقوف الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
وقوف ايران مع العراق وفتح مخازن السلاح
الايرانيه للجيش العراقي بالوقت التي كان
الموقف سلبي من الدول العربيه او الاداره
الامريكيه او الدول الاخرى التحالف الدولي
لمساعده الجيش العراقي فلذلك المواقف
العراقيه تبنى من خلال المصلحه الوطنيه
العراقيه يعني شاهد ردود افعال الشارع
العراقي في 2003 عندما اسقط النظام صدام
حسين كان موقف الشارع العراقي شاكرا
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن عندما
تبدل المزاج الامريكي وتغيرت السياسات
الامريكيه بدا يتغير المزاج العراقي
الشارع العراقي لا يبني مواقفه على مواقف
مسبقه طائفيه وانما من خلال المواقف
والمصالح التي تنعكس ايجابيا على الشارع
العراقي الدوله العق سيد عباس التواجد
والحضور الايراني في العراق وما يمارسه
وطبيعه هذا التواجد الا يصبح معه طرح
مساله السياده مساله مبالغ فيها هناك
اتهامات وكلام حتى من قبل اطراف فاعله في
داخل العراق كالجانب الامريكي او حتى
اطراف عراقيه وتتكلم عن تجاوز الدور
الايراني وتدخله في مسائل تمس وتهدم حتى
مفهوم
السياده الموضوع الان يعني لا احد يعتب
على الشعب الكويتي عندما استعان بال 70
دوله عندما ما اراد تحرير الكويت ولا احد
يعتب على الشعب العراقي الان عندما يستعين
بايران او امريكا او اي دوله لمحاربه داعش
العراق الان الساحه العراقيه مفتوحه
لمساعده لا للسيطره لا للهيمنه لا ل سلب
القرار السيادي الوطني الان لو قد قامت
قطر يوم يوم غد بارسال الطائرات
والمساعدات للجيش العراقي انا ساكون هنا
واقول شكرا قطر وغيرها السعوديه نحن ليس
مواقفنا مواقف مسبقه للادانه نحن نقيس
مواقفنا في العراق من خلال ما يقدم الى
العراق والى دعم العمليه السياسيه في
العراقيه ضيفي من عمان دكتور حيدر سعيد
كيف تجد التواجد والتاثير الايراني في
العراق هل يحترم مفهوم السياده العراقيه
ام انه
يتجاوزها يعني بالتاكيد ايران اعتقد البلد
ذات النفوذ الاكبر في العراق
يعني والى حد كبير ما ادري هو مفهوم
السياده ربما مفهوم انتهى في العالم منذ
30 سنه طبعا لا اريد ان ابسط المساله لكن
بالتاكيد يعني نحن لا نستطيع ان نتحدث عن
اراده عراقيه كامله وانا في تصوري كانت
امام الدوله العراقيه وامام الطبقه
السياسيه العراقيه والشيعيه تحديدا اكثر
من فرصه لكي تبني اراده قويه وتحديدا يعني
فيما يخص ايران ان تكون هناك اراده مستق
مستقله لا ادري ربما بسبب اضطراب الاوضاع
في العراق منذ
2003 والعامل الاساسي انا في تصوري ما بعد
الربيع العربي ونمو قراءه لدى رئيس
الوزراء السابق نوري المالكي بان المنطقه
الان تشهد صراع محاور وخنادق
طائفيه ولا يمكن للعراق ان يكون بمنجا عن
احد هذه المحاور محور قطري سعودي تركي
ومحور ايراني سوري ويضم حزب الله في لبنان
وعلى العراق ان يختار الانضمام الى احد
هذه المحاور تحديدا هذه القراءه نمت ما
بعد الربيع العربي يعني خليني اقول منذ
2010 و21 لاحقا في ولايه المالك الثانيه
المالكي اتجه باتجاه ايران واتجاه لتعزيز
هذا المحور بوجه المحور الاخر يبدو
لي الى حد كبير كان كان جزء كبير من
القرارات الاستراتيجيه العراق راقيه
بالحقيقه قرارات ايرانيه لم تكن قرارات
عراقيه وبالمقابل التعامل الايراني انا
اعتقد هناك مركب ايديولوجي سياسي لتعامل
ايران مع العراق من جهه نعم ايران تنظر
الى العراق على انه بلد شيعي او جزء اساسي
منه يشكل الشيعه وبالتالي هي تتعامل مع
الشيعه في اي مكان بالعالم من هذا المنظور
الاديولوجي وايران بلد ضو طموح امبراطوري
يعني منذ قرون التعامل الاخر هو هذا
التعامل السياسي ايران تعتقد انه لا ينبغي
لهذا المحور ان يكسر مثل ما دافعت عن نظام
الاسد يعني دفاع وجود في تصورها كسر
منظومه اي كسر اي ثلم في منظومه الحكم في
العراق التي يشكل الشيعه الجزء الرئيسي
فيها هو كسر لهذا المحور فبالتالي دخلت
ايران بكل قوه للدفاع عن منظومه الحكم في
العراق انا اتصور اذا ما اذا عندي وقت
شويه بس هي القصه وضو انا اعتقد ا ايران
حتى مع مع قصه داعش ايران لا تريد ان تجر
الى حرب استنزاف في العراق ايران تبقى
يعني تامل بان تلعب الولايات المتحده
الدور الاكبر في هذه المواجهه ولكن في
حاله فراغ او غياب الولايات المتحده ايران
تدخل مباشره ما حدث في الجدل حول معركه
تكريت الولايات المتحده كان لديها
اعتراضات على معركه تكريت انسحاب الولايات
المتحده هو الذي فتح الباب لمشاركه
ايرانيه بهذا الحجم وبهذا النوع طيب فاصل
قصير نناقش بعده الحدود الحقيقيه لعلاقات
العراقيه الايرانيه نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش الحدود الحقيقيه للعلاقات العراقيه
الايرانيه في ضوء ما صدر من تصريحات من
الجانبين اخيرا اثر تصريحات لمستشار
الرئيس ال تكلم على ان العراق هو امتداد
حضاري ل ايران دكتور لقاء من البديهي
عندما نتكلم عن ما مدا التاثير الايراني
حاليا في العراق عندما نقول التاثير نتكلم
عن ادوات هذا التاثير ما هي ادوات التاثير
الايراني في داخل العراق هو اولا التاثير
ليس حالي يعني فكره ان ايران تستولي على
العراق كما قال الامير سعود الفيصل قبل
اسبوع او اكثر هو بالحقيقه متاخر جدا لانه
ايران يعني كانت في اطار الاستيلاء منذ
عام 2003 بعد الاحتلال ومنذ الوزاره
الاولى لاياد علاوي وما بعدها كان هناك
نفوذ ايراني واسع او بدا تشكيل النفوذ في
الدوائر الامنيه خصوصا في وزاره الداخليه
وكان هناك تاثير في الاحزاب في داخل
الاحزاب السياسيه المؤثره وبالتالي كان
هناك انتشار ليس فقط من خلال يعني لا نقول
هناك ايرانيين يعملون ولكن الاطراف التي
هي قريبه من ايران كانت تعمل لصالح ايران
في داخل المؤسسات العراقيه لا سيما
الامنيه منها النفوذ الايراني كان واسع
النطاق على الصعيد الامني والسياسي وحتى
الاقتصادي وبالتالي امكانيات هذا النفوذ
نمت طوال هذه الفتره حتى على صعيد
الزيارات الدينيه للمراقد المقدسه في
العراق يعني الزوار الايرانيين مثلا فتحت
ليس للزوار ولكن للشركات الايرانيه عمال
النظافه ايرانيين مثلا اللغه الايرانيه
الفارسيه اصبحت شائعه في كثير من مدن
العراق بل في مطار بغداد تجدها بمعنى اخر
ان هناك عمليه تعود على
هذا الوافد الجديد على اللغه الجديده التي
كانت في العراق تعتبر نمط شاذ وغريب عفوا
دكتور اللقاء ولكن اليس هناك مبالغه تهويل
لهذا الضور الايراني في العراق فحتى
التصريحات الاخيره التي وهي محل نقاشنا في
هذا اليوم ما نسب او ما نقل عن المستشار
الرئيس الايراني بالحديث عن علاقه بين
ايران وتركيا نفتها الحكومه الايرانيه
وردت عليها بشكل او باخر الحكومه العراقيه
واطراف ومرجعيات في العراق اذا لماذا
التهويل في طبيعه الضو الايراني في العراق
شوف اولا من الناحيه الواقعيه هناك نفوذ
ايراني واسع وقوي والان بدات حتى الولايات
المتحده تنتبه الى الدول العربيه لكن
الاخطر من هذا هو هذا التصريح وما رافق من
تصريحات وما رافق من سلوك ايراني في
المنطقه في اليمن يعني مثلا تصريح يونسي
ترافق تماما وتزامن مع تصريح العلي شمخاني
الامين العام لمجلس الامن القومي الايراني
مجلس الا على الامن القومي قال ان ايران
اليوم على المتوسط وباب المندب هذا قبل
بضعه ايام هذا التصريح ما حد انتبه له طيب
اذا كانت في باب المندب والمتوسط فهي معنى
اخر كما قيل انها تسيطر كما قال حتى
نتنياهو تسيطر على اربعه عواصم هذا التوسع
الايراني لم يحتاج لم يكن بحاجه الى يونسي
ليعلن طيب يونس يعلن هذا الامر ثم بداوا
ينفون في ايران حتى لاريجاني في الدوحه
قال انه خطا في الترجمه والسفاره في بيروت
قالت انه ما اعرف غير صحيح او استنكرت
ولكن هذا يونسي ليس شخصا عاديا كما قال
الاستاذ الموسوي صحيح هو مستشار لشؤون
الاقليات هذا وزير مخابرات خاتمي
وبالتالي من اكبر الاصلاحيين في ايران وهو
الان مستشار لروحاني لم وليس سهلا كان
وزيرا للمخابرات الاطلاعات اذا هو حينما
يقول شيء هناك تخطيط له بمعنى انه لم يقل
ويخط المسال فيها توزيع ادوار ايران في
نشاطها الدعائي والسياسي تتبنى قانون يسمى
قانون ببكن قانون توزيع الادوار في
الدعايه كل واحد يصرح بشيء ومتناقض بحيث
كل من يريد ان يسمعها يسمع على هواه الان
مؤيدي ايران في العراق يقولون اذا ايران
جايه والحمد لله اعداء ايران يقولون لا
ايران نفت
بالتالي ايران حينما تكرس هذا المفهوم
الان نفسيا انها اصبحت في كل العواصم
العربيه او معظمها بالمشرق وان انها بدات
بكوين الامبراطوريه ماشيت فيه لكن هو تكرس
في الوعي وبدات الناس تناقشه في ما بينها
هدف ايران من هذا التصريح ومن كل
التصريحات المماثله ان تقنع الشارع العربي
في زمن الغيبه هذا زمن الضياع العربي
الحالي ان تقنع باللاوعي انها هي القوه
الاقليميه القادمه وعليه ان يصغر وانتهت
الم طيب سيد عباس الموسوي كيف تستطيع
بغداد كيف يستطيع العراق ان يحافظ على
مسافه بينه وبين يضمنها كجار ولكن ليست
كدوله مهيمنه
عليه يعني التصور العمليه السياسيه في
العراق ووعي الشارع العراقي وفهم
العراقيين المعقد للسياده نحن لو اردنا
التفريط بالسياده العراقيه لوقع اتفاقيه
بقاء القوات الامريكيه وضمنا ان ان ان
نكون تحت الوصايه الامريكيه بشكل مباشر
وسيطرنا على كل دول المنطقه لان امريكا
اذا ارادت ان تعطي دورا ل العراق تستطيع
العراقي بطبيعه الشعب العراقي يعيش عقده
السياده فلذلك لا احد يراهن على ان
العراقي يفرط
بسيادته مقابل هذا الى ايران او الى
امريكا او الى اي دوله من الدول الاخرى
النقطه مهمه اتصور الدور الايراني الان في
المنطقه يعطي ثقه الى اصدقاء ايران يعني
العراق عندما يوثق علاقته مع الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه لان يدرك جيدا ان ايران لا تترك
اصدقائها والايران هي بحاجه الى العراق
كما العراق بحاجه الى ايران العراق ليس
بلد فقير الع العراق يملك البعد الروحي
للارتباط الايراني العتبات المقدسه
الموجوده في العراق لذلك الايراني هو
بحاجه الى الالتصاق بالعراق اكثر مما
العراق هو بحاجه الى التصق بايران الوضع
الاقتصادي العراقي اكثر العراق يصدر اكثر
من 3 ملايين ونصف برميل بينما الايراني
يصدر اقل لذلك اتصور هي ايران بحاجه الى
الالتصاق بالعراق اكثر من الالتصاق
العراقي وانتها القرار السياسي مداها مدى
هذا الالتصاق اسال ضيفي اخيرا من من عمان
دكتور حيدر سعيد لو حتى ارادت القياده
العراقيه ان تحافظ على مسافه طبيعيه بينها
وبين ايران هل تستطيع ذلك
برايك
يعني بالمدى القريب المنظور لا لكن انا
اعتقد التح المطروح امام الطبقه السياسيه
العراقيه واكرر الشيعيه تحديدا وبناء رؤيه
تنطلق من خصوصيه العراق خصوصيته الثقافيه
وخصوصيته الجيوبوليتيك سنه 2008 السيد
عمار الحكيم كان في زياره للقاهره استعمل
تعبيرا مهما قال العراق يمكن ان يكون جسرا
بين ايران والعالم العربي انا كتبت قلت
متى تنمو فكره العراق الجسر وليس العراق
الخندق يعني العراق الذي مو بالضروره يكون
في هذا الخندق او في الخندق المقابل وانما
العراق الذي يلعب دور الجسر انطلاقا من
خصوصيتها الثقافيه
والجيوبوليتيك للاسف هذه الرؤيه لم تنمو
خلال السنوات الماضيه لم تنمي الطبقه
الشيعيه العراقيه مثل هذا التصور تصور
لتشيع عروبي متمايز عن التشيع
الايراني بالنهايه العراق الان والى مدى
سنوات في تصور
سيبقى تحت فكره الحاجه الى الى الجار
ايران اك اشكرك دكتور حيدر سعيد مستشار
المركز العراقي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
شكرا جزيلا كما اشكر ضيفي من بغداد عباس
الموسوي مدير المركز العراقي للاعلام
واشكر ضيفي هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور لقاء
مكي الكاتب والباحث السياسي العراقي بذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء
خبر جديد الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ان